the john wick films feature some of the
most satisfying scenes in modern action
cinema
with that in mind here are the most
paused moments in the john wick
franchise
from the ink that shows off john's
violent past to all of the other shots
that are just plain cool
we all knew going into the first john
wick that things would get violent
what we didn't know was just how a
seemingly good-natured guy
learned how to beat someone to death
with a book or kill three men with a
pencil
we got our first glimpse of his dark
side shortly after his beloved dog was
killed
and he decided that he was returning to
his old life before he sets out for the
continental hotel
john got ready for action with a nice
shower revealing that this quiet
suburban widower had a glorious and
ominous full back tattoo
there are a few notable elements to this
piece of ink but the most eye-catching
by far
is the black lettering across the
shoulders which reads fortis fortuna
argue what
that's latin for fortune favors the
brave the entire scene is very shadowy
and goes by rather quickly
so unless you're both familiar with
latin and have great eyesight you're
going to want to pause it to take in the
full effect
once you do you'll see how appropriately
it sets the stage for the coming rampage
as jon will have some pretty good luck
while going directly at his targets
like a wrecking ball meanwhile the guy
who picked on an adorable puppy and then
spends the rest of the movie running
away
is going to have a pretty rough time the
fight scenes in john wicker often hail
to some of the best in modern action
cinema
and justifiably so but they're not the
only thing about these movies that
deserve praise
one element that's often overshadowed is
just how beautifully shot these films
are
for those of you looking for a new
desktop background or phone lock screen
john wick provides plenty of options one
of our favorites is a shot of john
walking away in slow motion from a
burning pile
of money after he takes on a church
that's a friend for criminal operations
the cool guy walking away trope has a
long and proud tradition in action
movies
so much so that the lonely island even
wrote a song about it
john wick's spin on the routine doesn't
involve an explosion
although a burning pile of cash has its
own intensity but what it lacks in
pyrotechnics it makes up for in pure
style
the slow motion the shadows falling
across keanu reeves face
and the flames coming up from behind
wick as he descends deeper into his own
personal hell
all make it well worth it to hammer that
pause button to get your screenshot just
right
keanu reeves isn't always thought of as
the most emotive actor
if you're looking for someone who can
pull off goofy's spaciness or zen khan
he's your guy
but if you want a performance that's
full of emotion and energy you might not
be your first call
but with john wick he proves a folly of
that belief true john has the same quiet
understated intensity that reeves has
brought to plenty of other roles but
that just makes it all the more
satisfying when he finally does snap
and snap he does his first face to face
confrontation with michael nikvis vigo
is one of the most iconic moments of the
entire franchise
thanks to that growling delivery of but
now yeah
i'm taken on back it's a moment so cool
that it was prominently featured in the
trailer and it makes the entire scene
incredibly memorable
it's worth pausing for a couple of
reasons for one we rarely get to witness
reeves and a full-on rage which makes it
pretty easy to believe those rumors that
wick is actually a supernatural creature
also considering that this scene builds
to reeves shelting
so you can either hand over your son
or you can die screaming alongside it
you might need to take a pause just to
calm yourself down for a bit
if you're the type of moviegoer who
checks does the dogdy.com before
watching anything
john wick probably isn't the best choice
for you nevertheless there actually is
plenty in the first movie for dog lovers
to enjoy the most obvious is the fact
that the majority of the film is focused
on a guy
making sure that everyone even remotely
involved with being mean to his puppy
is met with vengeance furthermore the
ending brings him to another furry
creature who needs a little help
the scene of john in the veterinary
hospital provides an emotional climax
that most relationship dramas would be
jealous of
that someone is a pit bull who's
scheduled to be put to sleep but this
soft-hearted assassin isn't about to
just let that happen without doing
anything
it's absolutely worth a pause when jon
lets his new best friend out of his cage
if only because it's one of the best
shots of the dog that we get in the
entire movie
it's not like we had any doubts that he
was a good boy but it's still nice to
get a good long look to know for sure
the first john wick tells us the basics
of the shadowy world of assassins
and their preferred hotels but chapter 2
really kicks that into high gear
as we learn about the markers they're
essentially a physical representation of
a favor owed to someone
while they're small enough to fit in a
pocket they carry a considerable weight
if someone has your marker you can't
refuse their request no matter what it
is
lest you bring the wrath of the entire
assassin well down upon your head with
their typical penchant for drama the
assassins have hidden needles in these
medallions so that they can formally
seal their favors with bloody
thumbprints
two rules that cannot be broken jonathan
no blood on continental grounds and
every marker must be honored
the markers embody the compelling design
sensibility behind the artifacts of this
deadly world and they make us wish that
there was a john wick artbook so that we
could see them in detail
for now we'll have to make do with
porting the few close-up shots that we
get that otherwise go by too fast
for a movie that's primarily about keanu
reeves finding exciting new ways to kill
people
a surprising amount of john wick chapter
2 takes place in and around museums
in particular the villainous santino
seems fond of surrounding himself with
fine arts
which has a nice side effect of
providing viewers with some suitably
dramatic shots
and that's not the only reason for all
that art it's definitely worth giving
the pause button a workout to take a
closer look if you do you might be able
to figure out a little bit of the
symbolism on display
take for instance a scene when john
meets up with santino agreeing to the
favor his marker is demanding
the two of them sit in front of giovanni
fattoris la battaglia de custoza
an 1880 painting depicting a battle from
the third italian war of independence
despite outnumbering their enemies 120
000 to 80 000
the italian army was forced to retreat
leaving behind
thousands of prisoners it's probably not
a stretch to say that santino parking
himself in front of a painting
about how overwhelming numbers aren't
always going to result in a victory
might have some thematic resonance this
was my father's collection i see a
little more than just paint on canvas of
course
saying that the john wick films of great
fight scenes is like saying that water
is wet
these movies are essentially six hours
of non-stop crazy battles with a few
breaks for hanging out with dogs
if you're looking for the highlights of
the highlights they don't get much
better than the hall of mirrors fight in
chapter two we're not sure why santino
even has a hall of mirrors for such a
prolonged throwdown
but since the prevailing concern for the
john wick design team seems to be
how cool does this look that logical
concern doesn't really matter
what does matter is that this scene
provides some of the best visuals in the
series from the battle between john and
the bodyguard played by ruby rose
to the kaleidoscopic fights where john
and his opponents are surrounded by
infinite reflections
not since the matrix revolutions have we
been excited to see reeves duking it out
with infinite identical opponents
the entire sequence is about seven
minutes of pure adrenaline
and virtually every shot is worth
pausing to take it all in
who says gracious violence can't be
absolutely beautiful
despite its unwieldy title john wick
chapter 3 parabellum
doesn't waste a lot of time within 7
minutes jon is beating a giant man to
death with a book
in the middle of the new york public
library and it doesn't slow down from
there
about 15 minutes later he's fighting
people while riding a horse through
midtown manhattan
it's a wild ride the library fight isn't
the kind of scene you pause though
even if it is one you'll want to watch
over and over again the fight scene that
follows however
is one that will have you freezing the
action if only to see how they managed
to pull off the visual effects without
actually killing any of the actors
when a group of assassins corner john in
a warehouse full of antique weapons
that someone has kept incredibly sharp
we get some knife throwing that goes
past brutal and into hilarious territory
this scene demands to be paused for a
couple of reasons first it's pretty fun
to tally up the number of knives that
jon manages to hook at his opponents in
40 seconds
it's 19 if you're curious also you'll
want to marvel at how convincing the
special effects of knives sticking out
of people are
just as our initial glimpse of john's
tattoo in the first film requires
pressing pause to get a good look at it
the scene in parabellum that finds him
arriving at the tarkovsky theater in
hopes of escaping the bounty on his head
demands the same
for one there's a ballerina who has a
similar tattoo proving that while jon
might be the most unstoppable graduate
from the director's training program
he's not the only one this trip
backstage is also full of world building
that goes by just a little too quickly
for obsessive fans the other ballerinas
suffering for their art the group
practicing jujitsu
and even the paintings lining the
director's cozy studio are all crying
out for more attention
the big attraction though is a golden
rosary that john hands over
a ticket taken by the director that's
then used to brand him with an inverted
cross
right on his tattoo of all the moments
that show us the secret societies in
john wick
this is the one that feels the most
insular everyone involved knows exactly
what's going on what's being demanded
and what the price will be as much as we
like digging through the background for
details this is one that we like to slow
down just so that we can piece it all
together
you can never come home again john's
meeting with the elder a mysterious
assassin king who lives in the desert
outside casablanca while dreaming of
elaborate displays of fealty
doesn't exactly go well sure he gets his
excommunicado status eliminated but that
only lasts for about 20 minutes before
he's back on the high table's bad side
and he has to pay a significant price if
you haven't seen this scene let's just
say that jon takes off his wedding ring
the hard way
even by the standards of violence in
this franchise this moment is both
intense and
unexpected partly because it's jon doing
something to himself
rather than to someone else it turns out
that the only person in these movies who
can really take on john wick
is john wick himself so whether it's
your first time watching chapter 3 or
your 40th
you're going to want to take a quick
break right before it happens and take a
deep breath
maybe get yourself a glass of water and
mentally prepare
just have the pause button ready for
when john slides his hand across that
table with a chisel on it
you'll thank us later your choice is
yours
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one